you know what's interesting i was just
thinking you're kind of like so you're
helping girls right yeah and guys as
well but yeah yeah yeah but like you
also like are kind of the guy that like
has the rotation right that's what you
said that's he just said you wanted like
with the open relationship
oh yeah okay
yeah i was just like
but i mean it's like but you know i
think
especially
half of the time when i'm coaching you
know my clients it's kind of more i have
them like a very honest honest policy so
it's kind of like you said that if i get
involved with a girl and if i'm out of
stage where i'm not looking for anything
serious or if i'm open to whatever i'll
be like look this is where i'm at take
it or leave it and that's what i
encourage everyone to do
um
for
half of the things that i say for my
clients is just telling them the truth
that society
is is truthing the lies that society has
told them so
you see you said this is who i am take
it or leave it right because this is
what i i look at the world
whether we want to like agree or not
yeah like men and women
there's like a an attractive scale in
this general society yeah you know
people will find kim kardashian
somewhere on the scale when people might
find oh no
a woman just off the street on the scale
right yeah so do you think now
i'm not judging you but do you think
if you were fat
right yeah
i'm balding or something right that you
could tell a woman ah you know i'm gonna
see a couple of women
like do you think that there's there's
pretty privilege and there's rich
privilege
right
yeah but what if you're a fat and broke
i could tell her but it doesn't mean
she'd accept it
basically what you're saying is would
less women accept that obviously yeah
yeah
less girls would give him a chance to
begin with
so those types of guys are
going back those types of guys are like
are becoming the incel guys yes do you
know what i mean and like what i've seen
in this quote-unquote red pool community
manosphere there's a lot of angry
[ __ ] guys man yeah like there's a lot
of
all the time guys oh my gosh especially
in my comment yeah like respectfully
like feel free to you know send super
chats i love you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
took me for a surprise when i first got
onto the space cause i was like i was
like being called ugly every single day
i was like god damn
honestly i think half of it is they're
angry at
themselves but it's more like of course
because they many many because
they've been sold a lie we all have
like i think every i think any guy any
girl as well but mainly guy any guy who
gets to a point where
you know
he
can attract women realizes all this [ __ ]
he's been told when he's younger is
nonsense
about
having about what to do because a lot of
a lot what these guys do is they
basically simp for a girl and they've
been told that symptom for her is gonna
get her love
and then that doesn't happen and then
they get angry at the girl and it's like
well
at some point but you know who told him
to do that
well yeah disney feminists
facts
that's true feminists told them to do
that that's true
they said listen be more in touch with
feminists
and films like all of that [ __ ] like be
the prince charming and he's like hang
on tyrone over there
yeah
just slid inside your vagina right and
he didn't have to do [ __ ]
how come he can't okay but they lie to
girls too they just lie in a different
way that's true so they lie and tell you
that like the guys that you want are
just gonna like magically pursue you and
make you the center of their world and
all this stuff will happen you know
but like the guys we want aren't going
to do that you know that's the irony
isn't it
someone who would actually do that for
you is not the person that you would
want no because i think that's awesome
but it's more because like usually the
guys that do that don't see really value
in themselves
that like simp super hard don't value
themselves because like i've had guys
like where
they're just so into me so fast and i'm
like well what's wrong with you and i'm
not saying that to like put myself down
but i'm like you don't know me
like so
bro
oh my god
that comes down to them looking for
something like let's say it's a it's a
um
a marvelous son
yeah he might be looking for you to
replace his mom so that's why he he
might be
coming to you thinking oh she's gonna be
the
my my whole she can feel my whole just
gonna play the matriarch in my life
exactly yeah exactly yes exactly but
then yeah sorry so that makes that will
make them attract uh not even attracted
to you attached attached to you and then
in their head they're thinking okay
this is what i do this is what i got to
do this is what i go do and this is what
i go do to make her happy
meanwhile he's not even making himself
happy or thinking about his own
interests you understand so i think
yeah there's i think that happens a lot
but
i think most guys are scared to even
unlock that side of their thoughts if
that makes sense yeah i'm saying so then
all of this starts to happen
and then the girls are like because they
will present someone they think
they want to be to the girl yeah then it
might be something else and then that's
how it will break down yeah it didn't
start on a proper
foundation yeah yeah yeah people are
lying man like i think people are lying
to themselves mostly yeah and then
they're lying to other people and
they're expecting
people to actually um understand them
and that's why i think like i said when
the whole this whole dating thing is
changing it's changing
because people are a little bit becoming
a little bit more honest now like the
podcast generation has arrived and
everyone's talking about it and becoming
a little bit more honest but
generally people i just really do think
that honesty is like the best policy and
it's like
as a man
you know like i said you know what you
want
tell them what you want as a woman
the thing is with a man i feel like in
these days sometimes men have more
realistic
wants than women do yep that's what i
generally would you agree with me saying
that women think short term
and men think long term is that like
kind of what you're saying as well
what do you mean
girls think oh
for now life if you from like in my
in my experience speaking when i speak
to girls and i'm like oh so what do you
see yourself bear in mind
i'm 22. yeah so like for me
when i'm asking girls my age okay cause
30 where do you think you are they're
just thinking um
they're not thinking about yeah you're
not thinking about whatever yeah don't
get twisted that's not every girl's like
that of course yeah but then you ask a
guy he's like yeah i'm trying to one two
three four five yeah
because girls don't think so long term
yeah
they like they don't they're more
careless so what i would i
i agree in that sense i would say that
i think a lot of girls if you ask them
you know if they're young and you go oh
where do you want to be when you're 30
relationship wise
i think a lot of them will be able to
tell you
whereas i think guys would be like oh if
i'm married by 30 yeah that's calm but
if i'm not then i'm not because a guy's
not making his focus the woman yeah well
yeah yeah a woman's making her focus
demand you know what i mean and i think
women are attracted to that that's weird
sometimes yeah is it i think women are
choosing guys who
are more focused on themselves than
doing something or building something
yes oh there's nothing worse than a guy
that puts you on a pedestal because we
can't live up to it
like i've that's what i don't know what
like sometimes i'll
like i don't know sir there's a certain
type of guy that just like
when they meet me they just get like
they put me on this like pedestal and i
just can't like live up to it you know
what i mean
i don't know
but they're there what do you mean
what's happening
[Music]
i gotta think about how i wear